leave me alone oh my hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica now unfortunately or
fortunately depending on what you think
everything in the game has changed and I
don't just mean like I said in the last
episode even the way I have to approach
the game has now changed because
everything wants to kill me dead
that is simply a fact everything now
wants to murder me
break my ship that I built for so much
fun and stuff and they want to cavitate
me until I explode and I know I'm not
using the word cavitate correctly
because someone here by the name of
Aiden Patman Clarke has corrected me so
Aiden says mark cavitation is a real
scientific term when a submarine
propellers turning extremely fast in a
very high pressure making the water
around it boil which creates loud noises
and visible steam combat submarines have
a stealth mode in which the propeller
turns slowly to prevent cavitation just
a word from an ex naval submarine pilot
so they actually know what cavitating
means and now we know that as well also
Steven Fox who said f is for friends
that you don't even have U is for you
are lonely and is for no child sport
down here oh but down here in the deep
blue sea and then hunter ship look and
said mark the blueprint for the decoy
that you can put in the Cyclops is in
Life pod for Life pod for is by the
Aurora which means we're going to have
to go over there and then there's no
horse who said hey mark just a theory
but the base might have sprung a leak
when you rammed up submarine into it
which I don't remember doing I don't
think that was my fault
it was the weird bug where I go in there
and it suddenly jolts to the left so not
my fault but we've got a mission to do
we've now got the jet upgrade in this
bad boy which means ooh oh that is that
is quite a bit more responsive I do like
that a lot why couldn't it been like
that
baseline love why oh did I just ram into
my goddamn okay there we go
welcome I better not have sprung a leak
in air you better not have done that to
me alright fine man I'm going to trust
you on this one but now that I've been
playing the game and now that this
actually this release got released to
the full version it for the public I'm
still in the developer version of the
game but the full version has been
released and there are a few other
things that I need to be mindful of
there are upgrades to the Cyclops that I
can make and these are important because
they help with things like me being
attacked by monsters
there's a shield upgrade there is a
obviously the decoy thing there is also
a mapping scanning type thing that you
can do that will help you in terms of
just being able to know the environment
that you round so I don't slam into them
with my hull and break everything in my
ship but I've got a mission because with
this new update there have been jumping
ahead slow am i still cavitating gosh I
hope not I really hope not
so with this update I've got a few new
avenues to go there are the alien caches
that are now available in the crack
field and the mushroom force so I could
go to either of those and pick up some
new ion crystals which I do desperately
need and also I need to go now to every
single life pod because not only in life
pod 4 is there the decoy tube but every
single one of those lifepods has an
informational
I'm a bobber which means that I need oh
it is night which means that I need you
go do that thing
oh hi forest I keep forgetting that I'm
directly below the island every time I
go there which is awfully nice I suppose
for some comfort so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to go to the crag field
because that is actually the one that is
closest to me and I don't believe I'll
believe there's too many horrible
monstrosity down there and I know I'm
cavitating right now but I just need to
get there quickly because soon something
pops up on my radar that's going to be
super evil I'm gonna go to go to super
silent but this thing that's changed the
most about this game and what I was
saying about how I need to approach it
differently is I'm not safe anymore
there is no safe I followed in the ocean
desperately clinging on to something and
before I had a cyclops that was
indestructible and now if I go down into
the fiery pits of Hell where I wanted to
build a base that ain't going to work
too well for me I just pissed my pants
as you can see yes it's all just going
to [ __ ] very quickly but we've got a
whole new world to explore and a new way
to do it so let's try to get these alien
caches while we can and then hopefully
build a base down deep in the depths
which is still something that I want to
do and still my pro let's go
I see it's coming right for me you don't
know where I am silence I'm wrong what's
in the water that's so spooky what's in
the water that's so spooky unsee
oh god oh god it surrounded
Oh God huh what's that this fish okay if
why is it right on top of me where is it
okay bye huh
Oh No why would you do this to me why
would you do me I think I'm near the
crack field but it's goddamn nighttime
I'm gonna go sleep in my bed with Leif
until the night goes away let me live my
life again
why why do they have to make these
changes oh why did they do it okay at
least I can see now Oh
mysteriously the monsters are still
there I gotta actually look at the
camera system to try to find where I am
I think is this the crag field this
looks like it might be some sort of guy
what I in oh god damn it I'm silently
running why I'm freaking silent brah
okay they can't seem to hurt me but
that's okay oh my god I'm surrounded oh
my god that's terrifying there's so many
of them
ah good well I'm I'm definitely stopped
I'm silent at least you can't hurt me so
that's good so those don't seem tough
enough to be able to do some damage but
that's weird considering I thought we
still hold down oh now we have external
hull damage great it wasn't there before
look bad no joke creature attack go to
silence oh my god there repair it
we're gonna go repaired ya wanna I don't
wanna okay here we go can find it oh my
god stop just leave it alone it's not
worth the man it's not worth it leave me
alone
oh my god why why okay
okay I'll pick this up all about here
there guys push okay so somewhere in
here somewhere in here there is an alien
cache I've got to find it because
there's alien data in there that I'm
gonna need whole systems online is it is
that true
are all systems online you sure about
that or are all systems about to blow
let me drink my piss that's the only
thing that can bring me comfort in these
trying times I thought I was on silent
running can you please go to silent no
don't sound the horn don't sound you
want to sound the horn I ain't gonna
sound the goddamn horn you freaking
don't do that okay silent running
get off or on silent there's damage I'll
get it in a second
you stop my god is lethal here it's Rick
big and lethal you want to kill me they
want to kill big bucks pain I won't let
them do that although I don't know if
I'll have a choice in the matter
alright you know what I'm just gonna go
out and I'm gonna break that [ __ ] out of
them because they want to pick a fight
they're gonna get a fight and you want
to fight huh oh oh you wanna fight bro
oh you better run [ __ ] or you better
run [ __ ] oh you better run [ __ ] oh you
better run oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah you
didn't think that you were gonna pick a
fight with me that's right that's right
that's right I'm right
you mess with big box bear you get the
horn teeth the marketers horn teeth
patent pending hey hey hey you want
brown to baby
you'd say one huh oh god you in my trap
you've activated my trap card
are you dead seem to be still be
punching this feels bad now this feels
wrong originally I was cloning but now
it just feels like feels like I'm being
cruel here you okay you stay down hope
you learned your lesson alright
okay then oh you want to fight I'll take
you all on
I'll take every lesson and I oh you want
to go oh and you cycle back cycle black
circle back I dare you I dare Oh what
can't escape
oh you can't escape me baby whoa that
meant that boomerang got in the way and
shouldn't have done that
yeah are you taking me were you carrying
me where you where you running off to
where you think you can run you can run
you can run you think you can just run
that's right wait are you dead or not I
can't tell
that's a lot of blood okay you're dead
yeah you dead
okay you dead all right took care of
another one man he carried me far away
why yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah JJ yeah huh
what you're venting your bro I'll take
it on one eye on you threes the charm
here sending the three musketeers down
to the grave the brawny Japs the Johnny
Depp's looking you dead he's dead and
they all must have been dead a long time
ago and I was just kept wailing on them
like that oh god I was weird cool sorry
I mean I'm not sorry at all in any
capacity but still sorry what are we
looking for here we're looking for some
sort of a thingamabob er which means no
sorry
that was my bad which means that I need
to either go exploring or I need to look
up where it is so I'm going to do the
latter because I know it's gonna take me
a while so I'll be right obey oh all
right so apparently I'm close by it's
just a little over this way
whoopty suite jet upgrade brah oh is it
down there please tell me there's
nothing big down there in the right
direction here whoa alrighty then
yeah I think hey no none of that
well now none of that let's not have any
of that I'll just be on my way and you
have a lovely day and I eat some I eat
some fire heat fire literally fire Oh
rocketing and the winner's circle where
the hell am I is this the winner's
circle
ooh oh hello alrighty then I'm stumbled
across it
alrighty then I want to fight I'll see
how extended for all your friend badly
okay you are you run off you run on you
you're smart you smart you stop the
fight soon okay so I got to go in there
oh no cool I thought I was stuck there
for a second okay so I got to go in
there under my own two feet
wait I literally went in under my own
two feet I did not expect there to be
oxygen in here uh speckled rattler the
gross okay I don't know if I'm gonna
need to wait how'd you get in here
oh geez um you douche whoa this is not
what I was expecting I don't know these
pink caps good for anything nice samples
whoo what's down there
death I hope it's death well I know
there's another way to go but there's
way to go down here right jeez all right
looks like nothing so far anyway yeah
it's just another way down there so why
did they build a cave or what did they
excavate this or is this naturally
occurring that is the question oh my god
okay well it's beautiful and I'm glad
that there's this nice convenient path
here but at the same time Oh what the
hell Oh oh my god it's another gateway
Oh
well no I on crystal for me but even so
there's a gateway here now I know this
probably doesn't work much like the
other one but at least I know that this
one is in the Krag field which is going
to be good because that means if I ever
do get down below and there is the
Gateway down there maybe just maybe I'd
be able to traverse between the two of
them I'd be able to get something out of
that but
go down there just in case cuz I want to
be thorough I want to make sure ok
alright I think that was the end of it I
didn't see any data pads or anything
there but that's good to know that this
is here because the crag field is one of
the most resource rich areas in this
game which means that if I need to make
resource runs this is where I'm gonna be
going let's see if I can remember this
area hmm
scoop office jet up greatest the first
oh my god it's amazing has got to be
night again I thought it was just day it
was just day alright so my next stop is
[ __ ] hell you guys are so scary why
are you so scary
stop being scary I supposed to be a game
about fun and exploration and love and a
hugs ah
hugs big bucks Barry a little too are
they're meant to go in the gut there it
is slow too far for a chest bump them
yeah you know for fun and happiness and
because we're friends and we love each
other
oh [ __ ] this damage okay I'll take care
of that later now we gotta get going
here so let's go silent running actually
fine
alright I don't think they can keep up
with me well I think I was there's an
impact when I'm gonna say he died on
that one because he disappeared off my
radar alrighty then breach breach breach
where's the goddamn ship oh this ain't
good how did I get damn Hall damaged and
I get all tablets why was I pointed in
the wrong direction
it's fine whatever oh no oh no oh no I'm
gonna save because I'm gonna be skirting
right past Leviathan territory
what is that
[Music]
okay no I think I remember where life
bought for was but I've got a bad
feeling about this
oh are you how are you I don't know what
any of you are none of you better be a
Leviathan and I know it's really stupid
of me to be on this fast but hey buddy
what are you doing on the surface [ __ ]
sorry Jesus but one thing I do like is
the speed the speed is nice I like I
like going this fast as fast is good but
the cavitating yeah that's bad but you
can so can deny the speed is nice a
welcome change from the previous
incarnation of this boy well is that
what cavitating is that looks like
cavitating I'm aware I also got to not
navigate myself into the safe shallows
and each this thing because that's going
to do an unbelievable amount of damage
and not be good for me generally all
over Oaks
uncocks okay so I think I know what the
lightbody is that I think I'm going to
be getting away from anything that's
gonna be hurting me
I don't know I'll leave those as sand
sharks are in comparison to everything
else in this game but I have a funny
feeling I'm gonna be okay I'm gonna be
okay and everything's gonna be fine
I just pissed my pants but that doesn't
mean the things are not gonna be okay I
like this though I will admit I like
this I have not felt this terrified it
subnautica for a while because the
threat is real and that's something that
horror games you know they're either
good or very bad at is maintaining the
threats and
something about the ocean and now the
fact that everything can kill me
extremely dead and will pursue me if I
come after them just makes the threat
all that much more real I know I know it
seems like we're here backed by the
Aurora and the Sun is breaking so I'm
going to stop for just a second it's not
the end of the episode just yet but I'm
going to stop right here fix all the
damage because there's a lot of it but
never and then we're going to have a
good time whoever but no I love this
like it's back to true form of what it
once was and and that's a beautiful
thing like I understand why the
developers did it because it needed to
be that way the cyclops couldn't be this
permanently established fixture that was
unbreakable considering the freaking sea
dragon was able to bash into a precursor
base with just its freakin head honker
which usually means there's a lot of
death going on I don't recall this being
here but I'm going to take these just in
case I need them huh our cell hell yeah
I'll take that
fine get more ion Crystal's I'll be able
to do better on that one and now this
thing is skippity Gouda oh my god
Geoffrey Billy Sam wasn't Marshall oh my
god oh my god it's been so long dude I
don't really need you anymore
I don't know how to make those upgrades
the ones I was talking to you about like
the shield upgrading one not I checked I
checked the upgrade module place and
that didn't seem to have any answers for
me and then I checked the I checked the
the Locker on the earth a crafting
machine inside my Cyclops and that
didn't seem to have the answer for me so
I don't know where it is and oh my god
this is so fast ocean cannon I've
already got that I'm just grabbing up
some supplies while I can because I
always need them you never know when you
need them and might as well get
now but okay I think that's all I need
for here so I'm going to carry on to
life pod for which if I'm not mistaken
it was the one that was floating upside
down just to the left of here I don't
have the the beacon on me but we'll see
what happens that that's a closed cut
they're around here somewhere and I got
to be careful because there are
leviathans in this area they will
probably mess me up to no end if I let
them oh there it is it's still there
it's still upside down that's so sad why
is that sad little fat I don't know
alright then I'm coming for you I guess
ah so apparently there's the decoy
blueprint in this one and I'm guessing
if I had to guess there boy I climb in
there now alrighty then how do I get in
you again oh the giant gaping hole that
that makes sense okay so I'm guessing
that the upgrades that this gives to me
means that they'll all come like the
shield upgrade and like the the decoy
and the other upgrade that belonged to
the Cyclops now we'll all come from
these blueprints and so if I got that
then that means that I should have that
wrong right a decoy baby how do I do
that I don't seem to have anything
someone told me that this was gonna be
where the decoy was and I don't see no
decoy here so maybe you could shut your
trap and well he didn't do anything once
I got that like I got the day to
download and it didn't do anything
oh oh well I guess you would have shown
up here but maybe I need to get more of
them maybe I have no idea or maybe it's
because I'm still in the experimental
build but if that's the case then I just
got the thing in them won't get it
anymore but maybe I can probably figure
out a way to reset that but just for
right now yeah I guess that didn't quite
work I don't know why but either way
that's all the time that I got for this
episode it's been a terrifying adventure
and it's only going to get worse because
I'm about to go into the couch zone
again and there's a lot of leviathans
over there and bad and I'm not looking
forward to it but that's where I'm going
to thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know you think down the
comments below as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
[Music]